[Music]
i
found this fun video
um no but hear me out
we've been covering the brendan shop
stuff because i don't know we're stuck
in his algorithm i guess i don't care
but here's the thing
somebody and i gotta have credit to them
by by the way
somebody uh joke world
okay i like that they spell it
like juice world yeah exactly
that's pretty funny joke
did us all a favor
and did a super cut
of all the comedians talking [ __ ] about
brandon shop i try to skip over the ones
that we've already done but there's some
that i hadn't seen that i was howling at
okay so this is when burke chrysler was
at the uh tiger belly
every time he comes in we make plans and
i bet you money the next time you come
here it'll be a year from now and i've
still not been met your family
and they're going to double down on the
who's that
who that who died who that
it's not funny man it hurts it's
definitely not funny my feelings i
i will make sure that happens it's not
gonna happen is it it's gonna happen
yeah it'll definitely is it because i
don't drink no no no no no one else
drinks in my family
[Laughter]
we can't i can't come over and do a pool
thing yeah no we'll do how about fourth
of july we'll have a big fourth of july
party you will you you can come will you
have one girls yeah i will yeah well i'm
home fourth of july right
yeah yeah yeah if you don't i'm telling
you right now
we're gonna have a we're gonna have a
brendan shop situation
if you don't invite the little pieces we
that's the worst thing i could say to
somebody right that is the worst thing i
can say he could have a job all right
all right so be [ __ ] careful dude my
daughter's love bread
makes sense and you're [ __ ] kidding
me right now dude who dat who doesn't do
that you're [ __ ] kidding me right now
dude
oh god oh
oh [ __ ] oh my god he just shows up with
really expensive cars
this is that resentment that all of them
have and they're just afraid to say
i did not know what was going on with
brian callan and and
bobby lee and all these guys i had no
idea guys honest to god for all you guys
that wrote me little [ __ ] side notes
that brendan was a [ __ ] worm and all
this
because me and john bernthal were
talking about him listen guys
i i don't know what's going on i don't
know who it's on that's the one thing
i'm sure about joey diaz joey diaz is
never knows what's going on
oh
i don't know what's said up there
anymore like i said
before we even start this conversation
mental health is [ __ ] king so
i don't know what happened i really
might kind of tell me i know that after
i did the podcast
with
john i thought everything was fine there
was no [ __ ] you know and all of a
sudden two days later people like joey i
think you're wrong about brendan he's in
chooch he's this he's that and i was
like hey guys listen
i know the dude he's a student of comedy
but then
no
i'm tired of using this phrase he's a
student in the game yeah there's a
student economy all right well then if
you haven't graduated yet right should
you have a show times regional yeah if
you're 25 and still on the varsity team
there's a problem brendon people work
for 10 years to get good enough for
comedy and actually get like things and
even then they don't get showtime
specials there were people 10 years in
there were still mid acts i mean it's
it's it
a lot of these comedians you notice like
the the bigger ones louis ck didn't
really blow up until he was older you
know he was a writer and stuff but i
mean stand-up wise oh yeah he had to do
a lot of [ __ ]
he works hard
i i have not it's like i haven't been
around brendan for 18 months
but when you open up the computer you
see you know when you go on youtube to
get music or whatever there's always a
one
brendan this brendan special
you think you think you've seen our
video i think he has
julie poppy
brendan this i say i don't even know
what the [ __ ] insane oh for those who
don't know well gringo poppy there might
be some new people listening that don't
know what it is
i'll sum it up with one phrase
i'll save you 27 minutes
that's it i like that you're not even
there's not even any energy before it
pick up a guy
he doesn't have the same energy as when
you like flick that little doorstop on
the
well spring don't even know you know i
watched the special it's on youtube
i watched like 15 minutes of it it's
brandon
is it [ __ ] hysterical
yeah no
but of course it's not okay let's give
it a little bit ahead here because we
have played that one remember this guy
from workaholics
don't buy the shirts i've been on steve
lee's podcast a number of times i know
they're my friends andrew santino he's
one of my best friends
both bobby and andrew are coming to my
wedding along with steve he's he's
actually very funny eric griffith is a
very funny dude
um you know they're my friends
as you know now i also i am a regular on
king and the sting and now the wing
king's sting in a wing but post the wing
is that delia i don't know they added
someone to king in the state yeah i
don't know
your other comics have your little fun
names i can't keep up with somebody tell
me who's wing who's the new guy but i
was a regular on the show i've been on
fire indicated a few times i've i've
built a friendship with brendan shop
brendan is uh also you know i consider
brendan a friend i mean we're not as
close as i am with the other people but
you know
always these little have you noticed
that right there's always these little
qualifiers little telling qualifiers
it just takes time you know i had a very
i wouldn't say i had a contentious
relationship with brendan at first but
you know which means let me translate
for you i had a contentious relationship
with him at first
it started off with me being like who
the hell is this ufc fighter thinking he
could be a comic you know
and then the reality set in who's
friends with and then you realize you're
in california and you're not allowed to
have honest thoughts you're not allowed
positions about things i've come since
to change my tune about that because
because i wanted to get gigs i'm with
you bud i understand why
yeah i mean i get it because it
obviously doesn't matter what people
think about someone's art if you think
someone's funny or not it doesn't even
matter that's not what sells tickets
whatever brendan's got his work ethic
whatever people cte he has cte that's
what brendan's got and a sneaker
collection they're really fly kicks he's
a real dime piece
like about him it works he's on like
five six seven shows he's that's [ __ ]
nickelback sells out like i hate that
and
the ryan secrets because he's not funny
and he's on five and six different shows
ryan seacrest
is one of the most prolific
busiest broadcasters in america good
point yeah and he sucks he has that
radio show he hosts like three other
shows he's just regis and kelly you know
he's like the low-key the undercover
howard starr like people think howard
stern's a big name ryan seacrest isn't
the biggest name in the world but he is
on
ten different things every day and then
look at all the things the executive
produces too can you really go down the
list he's in he was cause he became dick
clark's boy yeah i think he's not funny
but you know what i feel sad about ryan
seacrest
hustles you cannot take that away from
him he [ __ ] hustles you're describing
brendan's job yeah well so there's a
difference i'll tell you there's a
difference at least ryan seacrest can
speak english on a microphone okay he
sucks
he's built the thick boy network he's
got two specials whether you like him or
not whether you think he's funny or not
it doesn't matter
people love to hate him people love to
love him and they go see him he sells
out places you know what i'm saying oh
he sold out a long time ago
i'm still trying to get people to come
watch me
that was
you you're really please i don't want to
think i think i get blinded by my anger
if i've been in shoppers but you're
reading three through the lines like i
am right what he's he's saying what he's
he's saying it without saying it right
i'm having trouble in reality what he's
thinking is like i am funnier and he is
funny i like him
he's a funny guy he was [ __ ]
hilarious on workaholics he was great on
working on montez oh so good
um his wife was alex bornstein she was
pregnant she was hitting on them that
was so [ __ ] great
i'm a great comic you hear what i'm
saying oh he's saying it okay me i'm a
great comic okay you're gonna have a
good time when you come to my show i
just gotta convince people to come to my
show so whatever he's got he convinces
people to come to his show he's got
rogan's ear i mean there's not like
a without rogan's [ __ ] mafia dawn
blessing
yeah what are you gonna do that's that's
what it is and you're gonna tell me a
lot of people are not nice to because he
has rogan's ear of course they are you
know
so whether you like him or not i don't
really care he's changed my whole
feeling about that it don't matter if
you're talented or you're good i'm with
you eric it doesn't matter if you're
good or talented or you're bringing
you're holding down comedy you know
comedy as you would call it people think
about someone they don't matter if
they're friends dad did a [ __ ]
computer pursuit of happiness i remember
his life was rough
you're not all that matters is if people
come watch them that's all that matters
um in terms of business you know what
i'm saying but i have a real problem
with oh
we there's another one we haven't heard
sam tripoli words i'm getting bullied
and traumatizing and i understand he had
a crazy child on h3 right yes
you're 50 dude
okay you're 50 years old
you're a multi-millionaire you have
successful movies successful television
shows and you have a smoke show
girlfriend
wife ah fiance whatever it is at this
time okay
okay okay all right
you
that's not bullying okay yeah it's not
bull and listen you can easily say
what's happening to me in my instagrams
and my dms
is bullying but the bullying that
brendan experiences everybody that
streams experiences at different levels
of course being a big yard we all
experience it
and i won't call it that it's just [ __ ]
talking people are [ __ ] docking me and
that's fine they're coming out it's fine
i have an army of care bears coming at
me what would you call what bobby got
though what would you call that
conference talked
i'd call it cocked what would you call
it i would call it
domineered by his girlfriend aggressive
hispanic girlfriend yeah invitation i
don't really feel bad for people that
are [ __ ] millionaires
made fun of online i don't feel bad for
you that's right you that's that's your
[ __ ] biggest problem i feel bad
shout out to zac amigo by the way you're
wearing the amico 666 shirt shout out
edit or saying mean words are you out of
your [ __ ] mind you're a millionaire
right and you care about what somebody
on reddit says there are people that you
cannot eat remember hold on a second let
me go because i want to i was why i will
always love louis jay gomez and it's not
because he's nicest because he is but
it's i've always loved them before
even before we ever on a show he was the
one that told carl for who are these
podcasts you better make a [ __ ] show
about me i want you to make one that if
he doesn't do he doesn't cover a real
ass podcast he's gonna beat the [ __ ] out
of him i thought that was hilarious
all right i'll do it and relax and did
you hear the episode he was like we're
supposed to like be mean to them i guess
why the [ __ ] doesn't he make fun of our
show i want to be on his [ __ ] show
it's more about like he wants like even
if it's a bad thing he wants to be in it
and feels left out if he's not in it
cannot eat yeah there are people that
don't have the money to pay their rent
they cannot get their kids insulin
right i
am not privy to this drama
other than you're lucky then sir
it's spilling over into my world
this is another reason i think they're
mad
so i didn't know what was going on
i didn't know that we don't talk
i don't i didn't know what was happening
all right i didn't know what was
happening
and then all of a sudden i'm getting hit
up like
you know so whatever happened between
bobby
kalila and brendan however they whatever
happened whatever happened
whatever happened between annie who all
these people
i don't know
it had nothing to do with me
it has nothing to do with me and
honestly i don't care can i help you
eric move to new york you seem like a
person that would
correct me if i'm wrong he doesn't he
seem like a person that would fit in way
better with the new york comedy group
than the la comedy maybe i don't know
he's a sort of a
cali guy too yeah that's you know so
they all become some layer like level
california guy however and i don't
appreciate that the fact that the [ __ ]
is public that they're dealing with it
the way they're dealing with well to be
fair here
the person who [ __ ] started all that
wasn't brendan it was brian callan all
right we're not gonna let brian callan
off the hook here okay we're the broads
or the brock of the broad broadcasters
with the big mouths
this is why you know this whole thing
could have been avoided
if you just don't let women have
podcasts
what i'm with you am i wrong so many
things would be so if these [ __ ]
[ __ ] hadn't had their little [ __ ]
their little uh uh sewing [ __ ] session
like it's a [ __ ] little hand party
little sewing circle like they're at the
hair salon and gossiping about guys that
wanted them to suck their dicks if you
just get women off the internet none of
this would have happened i'm gonna say
no because the content has been amazing
yes no i hear desantis is working on
that can you imagine a desantis there's
a bill where no no females
are on the internet sorry we just can't
have it
call it thing and make a hot tub stream
bill i like that
twitch thoughts will lose their minds
money in the process of doing it so
it just so it's like it's all for
content you know
yeah
people need content we know
very aware so they sell tickets eric
buddy
but like you said it doesn't matter if
the content's good or bad if people are
coming
listen we're all carnival barkers in our
own way i'll be the first to have meant
that extra extreme again come on in see
the freak show
but we're just we were honest about it
right
oh so and so then it all it just riles
up all the fans who think they're a part
of it you people think you're what do
you mean you people
yeah
oh i don't think you can really do that
to that racist to him yeah we can part
of it that's true
these people don't care about you or
your opinion
okay
hey i'm still with him that's a base to
take yeah i'm still with him so you have
your own opinion and then you're coming
at me
bullying me
y'all like people are keep coming on my
game stream they're coming on my chat
they're coming on my instagram like yo
where do you stand on this as if it
matters what you think let me just say
something right right because i'm not
gonna hold on
asking him what his opinion is on
something is bullying him is that what i
got there and now going back to to give
merch credit he still has the la comic
in him we just saw new york comic lewis
jay gomez going like don't complain
you're [ __ ] millionaire you [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't care i don't care i'm
bullied i'm being bullied i'm being
asked to take a position between a
disagreement between two of my public
known friends
and on the other side [ __ ] lewis is
asking to be bullied
bully me more
that's right fire me you [ __ ] mark
gotta name who said this there's three
guys that said this on through through
text i'm going to show you i can show
you right i'm not going to say who they
are okay but they said let's guess these
guys we're team bobby
oh yeah we saw this clip oh yeah we did
okay so we're done with this sorry
why is she dressing like a hippie what's
up with that i don't know i hate her
yeah she is she is not lying anymore
so yeah by the way for those that for
those totally real accounts are like all
you do is talk about brendan when he
stops making us money i guess we'll stop
huh here we are tell them to stop being
hateable yeah
here somebody's seeking these [ __ ]
clips out oh shout out i gotta give a
shout out to ghost gun ghost gum excuse
me ghost gum
on uh
on uh youtube made a documentary a
little 22-minute documentary called
reddit's most hated comedian and uh
has 1.1 million views and guess who's
the snippet of us in there
it's really bad it currently sits at a
1.5 out of 10 on imdb which was the
lowest rated special of all time this
was after attempting to bribe people to
leave good reviews in exchange for cbd
oil
i'm not joking it also garnered massive
condemnation in the comedy space and the
internet the guys just want to point
thank you ghost gun we've been saying
that merch and i are in the comedy space
i'm really liking space hey
if you ever need to talk about the craft
of podcasts you want to talk about the
craft or how we need to get more women
and trans voices in this space we can do
whatever it is we'll sell out right away
what's the check look like what i think
everybody's really wondering
where do you guys get your ideas from uh
it's true listen you know
i'm a tortured soul my dad used to my
dad used to sell game boys door to door
when i was young it's true he did he did
he was telling him who were game boys
that was a dime piece he stole them he
was a dime piece it's crazy it's so
crazy
the fact that the man with the lowest
rated uh i don't want to hear it you
could work with the clip it's we're in a
big video yeah i'm not going to play the
whole thing because no